Hello everybody, hope that you are good.
Today I'm going to analyze a new outcome
and that's going to be Solana. I've
already done two, Chainlink and Cardano,
and you guys have been asking me to
chart Solana, so here is the video.
Now, if you want me to chart any other
outcome, please let me know in the
comments and I'll choose the one with
the most comments.
All these outcome videos are in high
time frame because we're getting ready
for the bull market. So, we're choosing
the outcomes that are we like and we're
charting in high time frame to see the
buy zones and the sell zones. All right?
So, as it's high time frame, we need
some context. So, the Bitcoin's
dominance chart is very important
because it makes a massive effect in the
outcome market.
I've already talked about this chart in
several videos, but I think it's a good
idea to update you. Uh we've been in
this range for 2 years. You can see that
this candle happened in the week of the
10th of May. Okay? And you can see that
we've been going up, down, up, down, up.
And now here, many many influences were
calling for an old season, right?
Because they think that this is an old
season. And I've been telling you guys,
these are no old season. These are only
altcoins rallies because what an old
season is
are these drops over here.
Okay? This is an old season. This is an
old season. But these are only
altcoin rallies. That's what I
understand. Okay? Uh now, this time,
uh I know it sounds weird, but yes, this
time it looks different.
And I don't know if we're going to go to
the bottom of this range
because what you can see that happened
in the previous times was that we get a
spike, like a a week to the upside, and
then we were rejected. It happened here,
here. It happened here again.
Uh in this one, too. Here, a candle, and
then the next candle is a massive drop.
You can see. And now we've been
consolidating here
for quite some time, to be honest. For I
would say 2 months. Okay? So So it's
showing us strength because if not, it
would just happen like in the previous
times and it would just go down again.
But now now it's showing us strength.
It's showing us resilience. Not like the
banking system.
Um it's holding this zone pretty well.
So why not? Why couldn't we break this
zone? Hold here as support. Okay? Maybe
we can go here to 52%. That's the
monthly in the monthly time frame, the
50 MA. Let's get that in a second. You
can see that this purple line is the 50
MA in the monthly time frame. Here you
also have these crazy imbalances. Okay?
So why not? Why couldn't we see
something like this? I'm not saying 60%,
but
52% and we're now at 47%. So a 5%.
I know it doesn't sound like much, but
that would mean a lot. That would be
crazy. And this chart is pretty much
when the Bitcoin dominance
altcoins are going to are going to trade
bad against Bitcoin. Okay? Because
Bitcoin is going to be dominant against
altcoins. So that's the first thing. I
don't like how the Bitcoin dominance
chart is looking for altcoins because
it's telling me that there is a
possibility
mhm higher possibility than the previous
times the price breaks out of this zone
to the upside.
And that would be really bad for
altcoins.
All right? Especially if
it can
hold this zone as support
while Bitcoin goes down. So imagine if
Bitcoin goes down now to I don't know
um 20 I've I've I've been saying this
25. We've already been there. Uh 22, 20.
Imagine if that happens while the
Bitcoin dominance stays here.
That would be really bad for altcoins
and you would see
altcoins getting wrecked. Okay?
Uh I'm not saying it's going to happen.
I'm saying that it's a possibility. It's
a scenario that you can't dismiss
because I know this video will get more
views if I said that altcoin Solana is
going to explode, it's going to go to
the upside, buy now. That would gave me
more views.
But, what's the point? I'm not here to
lie to you. I'm just telling you
scenarios and what I see in the chart,
and I'm telling you that the chances
of the Bitcoin dominance breaking out of
this zone to the upside are now higher
than ever before during the past 2
years. Okay? Now, I see here already a
a support
in this zone.
Um this is the weekly time frame. So,
let's see how the weekly candle closes.
But, if it closes above this line, then,
you know, that's fine. If it closes
below this line, then yes, it's possible
that we go
lower. Okay? Maybe even fill this
imbalance over here. But, for now, to be
honest, it's looking pretty solid, and I
think it's just waiting for the EMAs
to to come to this zone. Now, if you go
to the daily time frame, you can see
that we have just tested
the daily 50 MA.
Okay? You can see that in all the way
up, we've been going with it. You can
see even even falling a couple of times.
You can see all these fake outs. They
did here.
And now, it may be doing something
similar because if you check here,
you know, we fell
below it, and we've recovered that zone.
So, if this is another fake out,
and this continues like this,
okay? Maybe you can see something like
this, and that would be terrible for
altcoins. So, that's a scenario that you
can't dismiss. And I'm telling you, if
that happens, what's the problem? You
can buy cheaper.
And that means that, you know,
you're going to be in a much better
position for the next bull market
because you've bought cheaper, you've
bought lower. So, that appreciation in
price is going to be better for you.
If you watch all the videos of this
channel, you'll remember a a that I
uploaded 3 weeks ago. I think it was. Um
I was talking about the a scenario that
some altcoins might see new lows.
I don't think that's the case for
Solana. I think Solana has already seen
the bear market bottom of 7 or 8
dollars. I'll explain in this video
later why I think this.
But yes, remember that I was telling you
to be very careful with altcoins when
the rest of influencers were telling you
that we're going to see an old season.
And I was telling you that because the
Bitcoin dominance was not looking that
bright as compared to the previous
times.
And you have seen since then, since that
video, that many altcoins have been
getting wrecked.
Check Polkadot. Check Matic.
Check Chainlink. Chainlink was uh I
think it reached 8 and 1/2 dollars now
it's in 6 and 1/2 dollars.
So, I mean, I don't know if you guys
know this chart is called total three.
And this chart
is the is the crypto market cap
excluding Bitcoin and Ethereum. So, in
this chart you only have
altcoins and stablecoins.
Let me show you the chart. It's this
one, okay? The orange lines.
Um I mean, you can see that the Bitcoin
dominance
has been, you know, in this zone.
And we're in the same place.
And the total three, which is again the
altcoins, is is I mean, and you'll say,
"Yeah, there are exceptions like Pepe
yeah and other coins that have been
going up while the rest of altcoins were
going down." Yes, but even Pepe is
inside this chart in the total three.
Okay? So, this is the average of all the
altcoins. This is generally speaking the
altcoin market, the altcoin prices,
okay? Um you can you can see here
that the Bitcoin dominance chart right
now
it's at the same point at the same level
that it was 2 months ago.
Now, the total three, the altcoins, were
at that same price, okay? You can see
that it it went up with it because also
Bitcoin was going up. So, if Bitcoin is
going up, the the whole market is
bullish, and the altcoins were
following, and the Bitcoin dominance was
going up. Now, the problem is that
Bitcoin has been retracing, you know, it
has retraced from 31k
to 25,800.
So, that's a big retrace. We're talking
almost about um
almost a 20% I would say, doing some
quick maths. Um the Bitcoin dominance
hasn't dropped. You can see that it's in
the same levels. So, that is the reason
why
now the total three, the altcoins, are
getting wrecked because you see this
drop.
If the altcoins were not getting
wrecked, they would be in this same
area. But you can see that they've gone
lower, they've got wrecked, but the
Bitcoin dominance has stayed in the same
area. So, I hope that some of you took
that warning seriously, and and didn't
think that I sounded crazy because yes,
it hasn't happened in the same size, at
least for now, but I was telling you
that drop in Bitcoin from 31k to 25, 22,
20k at the same time as the Bitcoin
dominance didn't follow, and it stayed
in this zone here, or even higher, that
would be really bad for altcoins, and
you can see that that's already
happening. This drop over here
is not a small drop in altcoins.
I'm telling you, check the Polkadot
chart, Polygon, Chainlink, Cardano.
Check all of these coins. You've seen
the price has really dumped. And this
drop is telling you that. Otherwise, you
would be in this zone, okay?
Let's have a closer look at the total
three chart to see where where it is.
Okay, I can see that they've come to
this week, all right? Because this is
something that I always tell you guys,
and is that the price always goes back
to fill the wicks.
Fill the wick wick for the strategy,
John Wick, call it as you want, but they
always go back the wicks. And I always
draw two lines because I they always
fill at least 50% of the wick. So, you
know, this line here would be the 100%
of the wick, and this one the 50% of the
wick. And you can see how this come now
all the way to the 50% of the wick.
That's good, but if you notice the
chart,
it's not looking really bullish still.
All right? I mean, it looks to me that
we're still in a range. Let's try to
mark the range.
Okay? It would be maybe something like
this.
And then this would have been
a deviation, I would call it. Okay? This
this this thing here.
But yet, you can see that we're in this
range for now,
and it's not looking bullish at the
moment. If you go to the monthly time
frame, you can see that there is a large
imbalance in the chart that they are
filling, okay? Because you can see that
they've already filled
uh
at least I would say probably 50% of the
imbalance, but not the whole imbalance.
So, the question is,
are they going to come back to this zone
in the chart? Because yes, that would
tell you
that the the altcoin market
would see a big drop because we're right
now at $347
billion market cap,
okay? Excluding Bitcoin and Ethereum.
Um this would take you to the $230
billion zone. So, that's around
uh 30% drop
in in the altcoins
market, okay? That would be a big drop.
Uh I think the only hope for this to
happen would be if the Bitcoin dominance
goes up, breaks out of that range, and
goes up and holds that resistance that
we've had for 2 years,
and flips it into support and holds it,
while Bitcoin continues goes down to
maybe 22k, 20k.
I think that's really the only scenario
uh in which I could see the the total
three dropping to this box here. Okay,
but if it happens
I mean, it's not
it's it's difficult that happens but it
can happen and if it happens, you know,
the opportunities that we're going to
see in this zone they're going to be
crazy. Again, I'm not saying that it's
going to happen. I'm only saying that
it's a valid scenario at this point.
Now, if we go to the Well, no, let's
check that week again for a second.
Let's go and check that week. Because
yes, this week is in the total three so
it's you know, the average of all the
altcoins. So, for example, if we go to
Polkadot
they've already filled the the week
entirely. Okay, you can check this is
the week.
Um you know, they've already hit to the
dollar
and bounced a little bit now from there.
But if you for example go now to Solana
you're going to see that they haven't
filled that week yet. Okay?
That's the week and the week would be
around $18 or $16 and no, they haven't
come to this zone yet. And price is
still at $20,
so this is only telling you that Solana
is very strong at the moment and is a
very strong altcoin. Or at least that's
the idea that I'm getting from the
charts. Okay? So, that's also what I
think that um I mean, it's it's
difficult that we see such a massive
drop in the total three, you know, what
I was telling you a 30%
but I mean, if we see a 30% from here,
where would we go? Let's check. I mean,
we would still go to around $15, $14.
Well, say a little bit more because the
stable coins, you know, in the total
three, maybe 35%. We would go maybe to
$13 in Solana.
I don't know if it's possible, you know,
a lot of things have to align together
like Bitcoin continue falling, the
Bitcoin dominance
holding the zone or maybe even going
higher
to even 50, 52% and then yes, you could
see something like this happening, all
right? I think that these weeks over
here
they know they are good zones to to buy
Solana goes there because Solana is is
showing that it's been quite strong
compared to the rest of the outcome
market. So,
really if Solana comes to this zone, the
rest of the market is going to be in
this zone, okay? Or at least that's how
it's playing out at the moment.
Do I think I can go lower from here?
From $8? I think
I think it's very difficult. I don't
think I don't see Solana dropping lower,
but of course if it goes lower, then we
have this zone over here that is around
$5.
But again, I think it's very difficult
that we see these prices unless if
something big really happens in the
market that brings maybe Bitcoin
again all the way to 15K or even lower
12K, 13K and then yes, you could see
maybe the whole market dropping
and a lot of altcoins would disappear,
which is something that has always
happened in the previous bear market.
And is that you know, 90% of altcoins
disappear and we haven't seen that in
this in this bear market yet. Or at
least for now. So, who knows?
I don't know how the recession is going
to play out exactly. It's quite
uncertain at the moment, but that's kind
of like the only excuse that I could
imagine for the whole market to to crash
that big because yes, that would be a
crash if we see Bitcoin going again to
15K or 10K, 12K, 13K.
What at 25k? It seems
you know, quite a far distance to go all
the way there. Maybe 20k is possible or
22k. Let's see how everything develops
because at the moment it's very
uncertain. But, yes, if it goes low
again to 15k or even sweep the lows and
go to 13 13k, we're going to see the
market going down with Bitcoin. And
then, yes, you could maybe find a buying
opportunity
either in this zone over here again.
Okay? Or even in this zone here. But,
again, I think that
uh I'm not expecting that to happen
really, at least for now.
And I think that these two zones are not
bad zones to to get some sole some
Solana.
As long as the Bitcoin dominance is not
looking too bullish and the total three
is not looking too bearish. Okay? Um
I'll keep you updated about Solana and
the rest of the market. But, yes, that's
that's what I can see for now.
And if we check to the upside, there are
a lot of zones
that price should should go back to.
Okay? There is a lot of imbalances in
the chart. Uh the peak was at $267.
And now we're at $20. So, um that was a
massive drop, but in fact it was a drop
to
to $8 here. Um so, if you were here,
congratulations. You should be very
happy cuz you're in a big profit right
now.
Um still, uh well, let me mark the zones
to the upside first that I think price
will go back to, yes or yes.
Um I can see, for example, this
imbalance over here. That's around $136.
I also can see this one here between $90
and $60. Of course, this one over here
around $200.
Um here, no, they haven't left any
imbalances higher. You can see that they
are filling with these weeks. You could
tell me that yes, I mean this week is
quite interesting. They might come back
to this week here to the upside.
It's around 245. Why not? I buy you
that. I buy it.
But yes, you can see that there is a lot
of
imbalances to the upside, so
and I think also Solana has
a strong fundamentals and a good project
to push price back up again in the next
bull market. Uh why not? We could have a
really good bull market. But until the
bear market gets invalidated and we
officially have a bull market. I know
that there is a lot of discussion there
if we are in a bear market or bull
market. I'll try to post a video soon
um telling you uh what I think, okay?
But But I'll tell you what I think for
now. In high time frame I like the 20
and the 50 EMA in the weekly time frame.
And you can see that right now we are
below the 20 EMA. So this should push
price down to be honest. I think we'll
probably going to see this week over
here getting filled. Maybe not the 100%
but I think the 50% yes.
Um that would be
already a better entry because you are
talking there about 10% drop from here,
right? Yeah, 12% or 13% drop. So I'm
going to wait to see if that happens
first. Um
Well, I'm going to spoil I don't want to
give you any spoiler for the next video.
That's going to be the discussion about
bull market and bear market. But for now
what I think is that
at the moment we are still in a bear
market. So
you can't really dismiss the idea. I
mean I know that this pump here was
crazy.
But if you look at the chart, we are
still below key
zones in the chart, okay? We are below
the 20 EMA. So no fireworks at the
moment.
Um this pump was Wow, was insane, to be
honest. 172%
pump. Well, actually more. I haven't got
this week.
A 246%
pump. Wow. So, I know that many of you,
when I'm telling you that we're still in
a bear market,
uh you probably don't agree, some of
you, which I understand and I respect.
But, that's what I think. I think that
it is bear market until the bull market
it starts. Um I don't think we've had
any validation for the bear market and a
validation for the bull market yet.
Okay?
Uh now, I think, to be honest, that we
are above a very strong
support, because if you check this zone
here,
okay?
Let me mark it in a different color,
maybe in white.
You can see that we have been playing
around this zone for quite some time,
and it's holding a support. So, this is
why I don't think that this zone of $20
it's a bad zone to buy. I think it's a
fair and and a good zone to buy,
because that Those Those were the lows
back in summer of 2020 21.
Um you could see that this is a
deviation.
Why not? You might be right. I can buy
you that theory that this is a
deviation.
Uh let's see if this support holds. I
mean, we've tested it for a long time.
Uh the problem that I see is that the 20
MA keeps going down, and price is below
it. So,
uh as long as we are below the 20 MA, I
think there is a chance that price
continue posting us lower, maybe even
close a candle body below this white
trend line,
this lows, and that would be quite
bearish for Solana.
Okay?
Um
otherwise, if we see something like
this, closing a candle above it, testing
it as support. That's something we
haven't done, to be honest, yet. Because
if you check here,
we go above the 20 MA, we close below
it, so that that was not test of
support. The same happens here, the same
happens here, the same happens here. So,
if we have a candle
breaking above the 20 MA,
okay?
Like this, and then the next candle
test it as support, and closes the
candle above it, then you have
confirmation to think that price is
going to go to the next EMA, and that
would be the 50 MA. That would be around
$33, and that would be to fill this
liquidity pool, this imbalance,
over here, okay? So, that's kind of your
confluence.
That That's kind of like a good setup
for for for example, a long swing trade,
okay? Um break above the 20 MA, come
back to it, test it as support, and then
yes, you can buy uh some kind of
confirmation that at least
price can continue going higher, maybe
to 30k. Sorry, to 30k, to $30. And we're
talking about a 50% from here.
That's quite a lot.
I hope that you are liking the analysis.
I'm trying to be as neutral and
objective as possible, like always. But,
you can see in the Solana versus Bitcoin
chart, we're in log scale, okay? Because
um I want to show you something. And
what we are seeing here,
it reminds me of what we saw back in
2020 in in this bear market. Although,
this lasted, to be honest,
uh 4 months, okay? But, you can see that
this was this trend line that was
pushing price down. And then we had here
a very clear and um
bullish signal that was quite easy to
see, that it was a bullish engulfing
candle. You can see that this candle,
the top closed
uh right above the previous one. So,
this candle here I telling you to to buy
here or to or to go long.
Um
anybody that did so,
you know, they basically
bought the bottom. I don't think we're
going to see the same this time,
something as clear. Uh first because
we've been in this bear market for a
year and a half already, not 4 months.
So, you know,
maybe if you do the monthly time frame I
can see something different, but
to be honest now, what is still right
below resistance,
uh nothing nothing is telling you that
we are going to see something like this.
We might see another rejection and and
price continue going lower. So, the
chart doesn't tell you to buy now, but
what is telling you
is that uh
Solana is a lot stronger than other
altcoins because if you see this, they
are not making new lows. They are not
even that close
to the lows, okay? The lows are still
35% down. Now, if we go to any other
altcoin,
uh for example, Cardano versus Bitcoin,
you can see
the price
is quite close to the previous low.
Right now it's at
uh
9 or 10% distance, not 30%
and it might continue going lower and
making new lows. Or if you go for
example to
uh for example,
Polkadot,
let's check Polkadot.
You can see that price is actually
making new lows this week. It made a new
low, okay? So, is this chart what is
telling me, the Solana versus Bitcoin,
is that Solana is a lot stronger than
the rest of the altcoin market for what
I can see.
Let's go again to the Solana versus the
dollar chart and let's wrap this up
here.
Um yes, I'll tell you basically what I
think in a nutshell. I think that it's
very likely that the bottom for Solana
is in at $8. Okay? Now, if this year,
you know, the bear market continues
we have only started really and we have
still the a big nasty drop to come, then
I think that buying the lows or
in the best case buying this sort of $5
would be the best option. Uh I still
don't see that happening.
Uh
I find it difficult
to imagine at this moment, but I can't
discard the idea. So, for now, what I'm
going to look at is going to be Uh we
have this trend line, this white trend
line that it comes from the lows in 2021
that, you know, we've been testing it
for for support for a couple of months.
Well, since since since February really,
to be honest. Uh
now, we have this week here and we're
below the 20 EMA. So, if the 20 EMA
keeps pushing price down,
then I think that buying the the feel of
the week that's still a very good entry
for the next bull run for Solana. And
also, a different trade is if we see the
opposite, okay? If we see a break above
the 20 EMA
and then a retrace to test the 20 EMA as
support
because, to be honest, we haven't done
that in the past. We've always, you
know, break above the 20 EMA, but then
fail to test it as support. So, if we
see that happening now, okay? Then, I'm
a buyer in this zone at $22. Okay?
Because then I think that we have a
chance that we can see price going up
to the top of this liquidity pool and
that would also match with the 50 EMA
around $33. Well, uh of course, it's
going to take some time, so maybe say
$31 or so. All right? So, these are the
two setups that I'm keeping an eye on
right now. I think that because we are
in this zone between the 20 MA and this
support over here, you know, price is
getting quite choppy. You can see here,
okay? It's quite choppy. And I think
we're going to see an aggressive move
either to the downside, maybe to fill
this week, or to the upside to come to
this
um liquidity pool and the 50 MA. Okay?
So, that's what I think that Solana is
up to. I don't know if you guys agree or
not or if you I hope that at least you
like the analysis and I've said a lot of
things, so you probably agree with some
things and disagree with
uh others. So, anyway, guys, thank you
so much for watching
and I'll see you soon.